the surge in coronavirus cases is taking
a very heavy toll especially in the
midwest
the u.s recorded nearly 79 000 new cases
yesterday
the number of deaths rose by nearly 1
000. our lead national correspondent
david begno is now in saint paul
minnesota
david good morning to you i know you've
talked to doctors across the midwest
what are they saying to you gail i spoke
to a doctor here at a hospital in saint
paul who treats cobit patients in the
icu
his son treats covet patients going into
hospice care and his daughter's also
treating covet patients
the elder doctor says i don't know what
else to do to get through to people who
don't believe the virus is real he said
david
when people are diagnosed with cancer
and they don't believe the diagnosis
it doesn't have the potential to harm
other people but coronavirus does
and it is spreading rampantly across the
midwest
from the great plains to the great lakes
hospitals continue to warn that the
surge of new coronavirus cases
is pushing their resources to the limit
the latest example is right here in
saint paul minnesota
dr abi nahum says his hospital is seeing
more than 100 coronavirus patients
every day and doctors are exhausted
trying to keep up
have you found yourself lacking some
empathy for people
i have caught myself feeling that way
and
pushed it aside because i have to take
care of the patient
and why do you feel that way initially
because it
is difficult to
realize that somebody who doesn't
believe in it
is putting other people at risk the
pandemic is pushing restaurant owners
like patty whalen to make tough choices
he will close the dark horse bar and
eatery in st paul
until the spring because he is not going
to be able to use his outdoor patio
to safely serve customers i can't fight
something that's invisible
you know what i mean if i could take
covet out my alley and give it my left
hook i would
the virus continues to claim lives
like 65 year old sharon hunt a retired
school teacher
from milford ohio just outside
cincinnati she was hospitalized with
coronavirus at the end of
august she never came home from the
hospital
she died september 25th we spoke to her
son and daughter-in-law
jeremy and christina hunt who say many
people in their own community
still do not believe the virus is even
real
when they go around and saying it's less
than one percent
when that less than one percent is your
mother or your sister
or your nana or your friend or your
teacher it opens your eyes this isn't a
percentage that's somebody's family
member
you know miss hunt's family tells us
they believe she contracted the virus
from a therapist who was coming into her
home to treat her and gail it's notable
hans family says her husband was one of
the people who didn't believe the virus
in fact they say he went on the local
news
saying that he thought the virus was a
hoax but now that his wife died from it
he very much believes it and takes every
precaution
to protect himself he even has a lung
disease
and is one of the most vulnerable oh my
gosh david you had so many layers to
that story it's a shame that it has to
hit home for some people to finally get
it
i love patty whalen's response so if we
could all take covet in the
alley and give it a left hook i don't
even know how to do a left hook but i
would try
we would all do that people got to take
this seriously david begnell thank you
again